it's time for the lightning talks so may
I may I ask maybe people to make a
little bit less noise and keep their
concentration for the last half hour or
so and then we can all party together so
I have one announcement first somebody
lost this piece of electronics here does
that belong to anyone yeah necessary
works Phillip wants to say a few words
all right I would like all volunteers to
come on the stage now all PI data
volunteers there are more
I valetine silver no it's one of the
volunteers okay so real quick at this
point I would like to yeah thank all of
you and say okay I'm like half a year
ago Valentina nine I talked about
whether or not we want to do a PI data
this year and back then we knew it would
be a lot of work volunteer work but
today I have to say I'm really happy we
did it we started it I'm really happy to
have all of you here we really want to
grow the ya data science community
especially in Berlin and in Germany and
in Europe and yeah I'm really happy we
did this decision back then and we
organized this event so um Thank You
Valentin for being a great at organizing
the event and thank you civ serum
Vanessa and more great and there is
Oscar where's Oscar yeah you're there so
thank you a lot
and now we're come to the lightning
talks where is the luuk you're one of
the volunteers as well this is luke i
kind of said i wasn't doing a
volunteering anymore but i guess can I
have like the six lighting talk speakers
come up front maybe so can you manifest
yourselves where are you guys one two
three four please come up five one two
three there's one missing Siva ok
perfect ok maybe I just want to have you
sort of at hand so maybe you can have a
seat in the front row something ok ok so
maybe I can have the first one hello
dialogue and joy ok what's your name
Henning Henning welcome to the stage and
you've got five minutes and a few
questions good luck all right five
minutes is actually plenty because I
just wanted to say hello my name is
henning and i'm the founder of dialogue
droids i just moved to berlin signed the
lease last friday and yeah it's great to
have such a community here in Berlin
hopefully to scientists and yeah and a
dialogue droids we develop dialogue
optimization systems so we develop a
platform that allows you as developers
for your app or device create a human
interface so text or voice input to
machine translation yeah and yeah so the
company is just a few weeks old we have
small team working working on the scent
of problems and yeah we just got funding
and moved into our small office and yeah
it does what it says hey hello and in
case somebody of you is interests
in natural language processing and
machine learning I would definitely
would like to get in touch with you and
hear what you're building and if there's
anything we can do for contributing to
the community please let me know thank
you very much any questions dialogue
droids I have one question hi then your
application while your framework do it
were work on the app on your phone
locally or it is computing the cloud the
question was whether everything is
computed locally on the cloud I right
now we are completely in the cloud if
there's demand for local computation we
might also move it locally but might
also post some challenges because the
models might be very big and shipping
these around this not so easy another
question big round of applause for
heading and welcome to Berlin so
installing docker preparation for
tomorrow's tutorial by Siva who wants to
give you heads up on what to do to get
ready for tomorrow
okay so yeah tomorrow there's this
tutorial tomorrow morning and there was
a little link that was added a little
bit earlier today on the abstract at the
end if you click on the Internet's not
gonna work oh yeah okay there's a link
here tutorial prerequisites and
instructions and if you go there so if
you plan to attend it it gives a bit of
maybe well first that it's for beginners
that's how the tutorial is designed so
that was the mindset with which I
approached it so it gives instruction if
you can install the ocker before coming
to the tutorial will be useful if you
can register darker of account pull some
especially pull some images because as
you notice the internet quality here is
not that great and docker hub when we
pull images is quite slow so it's just
not going to work and if you can install
dr. Campos so maybe just by curiosity
how many of you plan to maybe attend
this tutorial okay and how many are new
to darker okay it's kind of cool so the
thing is like if you if docker is not
new to you it will be boring probably
about the same time I will try to give
some detail extras that maybe can be
still fun to to see ya so you have any
questions no so that's the main thing so
if you can check this out and because it
will be the way the tutorial has been
designed is really that its interactive
so that I'll show command and we we play
with it so it's not if you're just
sitting and just watching it's it's not
really optimal will be really good if
you have darker install and then you you
really try out for yourself and see
what happens and the goal i had when i
did this tutorial was that at the end
your your setup you know when the
following weeks or whatever if you want
to use docker you have a kind of base as
a starter you know to keep going and
keep learning on your own and use it so
that's the the goal you know so that's
all I wanted to say I don't know if you
have questions no any questions okay
thank you see Val take round of applause
and now a big round of applause for
Stefan who is going to talk about
Dewey's do you have me there might be
some ok so I think it's a chain thing
right yeah okay but no no these are two
females okay and when I didn't HDMI
connections that without of them or no
problem no Jo
well he was losing the video thing hello
okay so hello guys I thought I just
introduce myself I'm Stefan ports I have
been a researcher in the field of
computational neuroscience especially in
epilepsy research and I thought I branch
out and tell you something about
graphical user interfaces especially
because it it's been an issue at our
work at our work so we had the problem
that we had a lot of data of course and
we had some intermediate results from
analyzing brain activity and the people
in our office just wanted to know I want
to see your data please show it to me so
we went together and build some some
some results for them but this wasn't
enough they wanted to need to know I
want to search through the data almost
all by myself so we thought okay we want
to build the software where they can do
that in an unsupervised way from from us
as researchers
so we build a small piece of software
that can exactly do that exactly for
that we used mad blood lip as a basis to
produce the graphs that so we used our
code that was used before hand for
creating graphs but it was integrated in
a larger larger software project which
is layout and created buttons and Sand
Point different objects to interact with
using pie cutie and yeah this is
actually doable and it's fast that was
the thing that was surprised to me
because if you creates several
matplotlib images one after another that
takes like forever but there are some
tricks to it if you use a map of lip
animate and catch the background then
it's entirely fast enough to do a
complete application out of it it's it's
integrates quite nicely and with pie
cutie you have the opportunity to
quickly lay out your application without
too much working it in a static way if
you use a point-and-click application
for it or in a dynamic way if you use
Python objects directly ok I do have I
did have a demo prepared and what it
seems not to be working at the moment
yeah yes so if anyone wants to see how
how this is working you're you are you
can come to me after the talks and I
will gladly show you the on application
and operation and quark and the source
code attached to it so thank you for
this and one short notice if you are
from the cologne area and you or your
employer is hiring I'm interested to
thank you
thank you Stefan any questions thanks um
did you use the Qt upload widget because
i use that like five years ago was kind
of unusable or do you did you write
something yourself I said the kids my
blood lab widget so not just the qm h or
something like that because I what was
what what I ended up to using ok ok cool
thanks oh cool yeah it was a really long
time go so another question ok so thank
you Stefan and now we have Stefan
another one who is going to talk about
whatever i conned auto activate um I
think is missing I'll do a condyle order
ok oh hi I'm Stefan I do machine
learning and robotics fun stuff cool
stuff I'm not going to talk about that i
also have to do a lot of teaching and
like nothing is like Conda awesome
project because if you're in front of a
class and then like trying to explain
how to set up like the environment and
pavements that really sucks O'Connor
sort a lot of problem for me but like if
you in front of the class for the in
front turn people and you try something
out and it's not working you're like an
idiot because you didn't activate your
content vironment or something it's like
really embarrassing and annoying so what
I'm what I'm showing is actually kind of
embarrassing it's tiny but it's really
helpful like when you
every weird keyboard layout I can't type
with one hand so I'll just switch to
another project I have and voila I mean
you can environment normally you have to
do this like I don't even know sauce
Conda activate horse activates then
whatever environment you have I always
forget that and I guess I not the only
one so what I have here is just like
when changing a directory it just
activates the new content varmint and if
I go back and another environment
awesome great it's it's tiny so what I
do is like I have this like I sauce the
Conda ottawa kanata as h like a tiny
file that automatically looks in the
directory if there's a dot Conda auto
file and it activates an environment
like it's tiny but it's it's so nice to
not think about qandolak I don't know
any content commands anymore because it
just like starts that thing and I'm
there I'm happy and this getup
repository you can clone it or you can
write like five lines of like shell
command and that automatically activates
it I don't
like it yeah it just basically sauce
activate the environment that is in the
corner file that's it it's great in real
life I do actually like more interesting
stuff than that like the robot surface
is cool thanks thank you any questions
ok so here we have pandas categorical
d-type my handwriting is way better than
I thought it was and your name ever
forgot your name from this morning huh
so my name is Matthew everyone so to ya
about crazy resolution here and a
monitor that or a beamer I learned is
called just keeps expanding okay is that
legible in the back okay so I do a few
projects that sort of our soft on the
boundaries of performance of pandas or
trying to extend that send out a bit and
the mailing list we get a lot of people
coming and saying like hey I have this
big data and things are slow you know
how can i use your project and it turns
out they just need to use pandas better
so lightning talk title is it just use
pandas it actually works far far though
anything it does one particular use case
it one pick through aspect that is
rarely known sort of new is very
powerful is the categorical d-type to go
where for me with our will know this but
just show of hands who uses categorical
d types right like five people okay so
one common reason why pan is is slow is
object d-type whenever you have text in
a panda's data frame that is stored as a
Python string object that sort of runs a
Python speed is very slow it's often the
reason why your pandas code is slow so
we can so common examples of text that
might appear in a pan is data frame of
things like male or female or stock
symbols
these actually don't have to represent
it as text they sort of our members of
categories with a fixed number maybe
less with gender about a fixed number of
options and if we represent them
intelligent Lee we can be far more
efficient ok so I'm going to type of it
so it's gonna be a little too awkward
okay so here's the pandas dataframe with
some names and balances and genders and
we look at the D types there we find
that balance is a float and then name
and gender above object okay so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to change
gender be category we're going to see
how it's how it's stored in memory it'll
be it'll be pleasant ok so the line at
the top that changed the d-type so now
we're storing our categories referring
our gender column as a category so what
is that so it still looks the same and
we still do operations we don't notice
any difference it feels exactly the
Nobel pandas dataframe okay but if we
look
gender we see that sacado radio type has
two different categories female and male
so a category is stored as two things
one a unique index with one element for
each unique element of your of your set
we gotta bury set and a bunch of
integers in this case because only have
two categories we can fit that in a
single bite ok so now rather than
storing these male female you know
essentially billions and these very
large bloated Python objects they're now
being stored in a single bite this is
very important for performance so let's
go over to a less trivial data set this
is a small subset of the New York City
taxicab data set which records every
taxi cab ride in New York City from
certain period this is small sample dis
week answer to play with it and it has
you know lots of lots of fields in there
like when the trip happened where it
happened and these two things at the top
they are unique identifiers for that for
the taxi cab and their store does these
these sha strings and their what causes
things to be slow this data set so if I
have time so I'm going to group by the
medallion by the site unique identifier
and then sum up all the trip distances
and then find the people who have driven
the most okay we're finding the taxicab
drivers who are most active during this
period and here they are and there's a
small data set so it took 100 40
milliseconds not bad I'm gonna do my the
same trick from before I now takes 20
seconds okay so that is one trick that
can make your pandas code go much much
much faster this you know almost an
order of magnitude with very little cost
it stores much more efficiently a memory
you can sort on disk much better you can
serialize it it's faster with group by
operations it's a win for everybody
should use panic pandas categoricals
that's it thanks thank you any questions
please yes we have a question right
that's a great question so what happens
to someone who comes by who is it male
or female for example it'll it'll add it
into the index and you'll just add a new
value so you know female was zero male
was one new gender is value to uh I
think so I this is not my work by the
way this is recent work in pandas it's
great you should ask on the pedals
mailing list I think I've seen that work
well and it does work well so you can
add new categories so you can actually
have an infinite number of categories
well usually slower or does it when does
it become so this works very well so in
that data set there about nine thousand
unique taxi cabs in that particular
month or day of data there are about a
hundred thousand elements so it works
very well when you have a high number
repetitions in your column so it worked
very poorly if you have to sort of plain
text that would be very bad be storing
the categories one each so works very
well you have repeats like with male and
female there's two categories a million
records right so if somewhat if I so we
notice that gender was an eight by eight
by eight bit integer if the 250 sixth
gender comes around what happens and I
actually don't know the answer that
question it might work I suspect that it
works but am I not thank you all thank
you
what's your name today oh man okay well
I think you'll have to introduce
yourself I can't read from here good
luck hi I'm I'm today Steiner I work at
here as a machine learning research
engineer and typically working on
mobility mining problems and today i'll
talk about something that's a bit more
of my personal passion and that's
automatic machine learning so the
subtitle is a bit tongue-in-cheek so how
to put yourself out of work but it's
something that's kind of a consequence
of what this can actually do so like
many of you know that a lot of time in
when you do data science or whatever
research is spent on like figuring out
what model fits best and what kind of
hyper parameters are good ones and this
can be especially complicated when the
parameter space explodes a lot so it's
sometimes very lot simply a lot of work
grid searching sort like figuring out
what thing works best by your intuition
so it's kind of black magic everyone
probably did something like this in
scikit-learn try different
regularization parameters and so on so
there's a pretty obvious opportunity to
automating this so there's a pattern
that usually takes place at least this
is how I'm doing it so it's a sample n
equals 1 but let's try first like figure
out what what kind of model should work
here best what kind of parameter ranges
and then see and try which one works
best and what kind of things significant
outperform what what was the initial
baseline so that's something that
scikit-learn already has implemented
kind of semi-automatically so there's
already grid search all randomized
search and a lot of the at least linear
model classifiers and regressors have a
built-in cross validation that optimizes
some of these parameters so you don't
have to do it yourself but it's kind of
a semi-automatic think there's not much
domain knowledge stored into this so you
still have to specify your parameter
ranges and in order to solve this
there's actually quite a like active
research community around hyper
parameter optimization so this is a
class of techniques that figures out
what would be the best model hyper
parameters for something and doing this
automatically so what's also interesting
here is there is a competition on this
topic it's called Auto ml and has an
interesting set up its has multiple
stages at every stage they release more
data sets and it on the data sets are
totally unseen you don't know what the
what kind of structure they are so you
basically can't prepare yourself for
them but your models are already up late
uploaded on the their server and when
the data gets released there's a ranking
so basically it's totally blind learning
you have to prepare your like Auto ml
code that it can figure out what kind of
things work best on the data set and
what doesn't so I encourage you to like
open at least the autumn L orchid she
actually has a lot of proper research
citations that are behind this and oh
yeah they actually provides CSVs but
them so you can actually test on your
own side but the actual competition run
stuff on their server so it's kind of
like a girl type setup and it's hosted
somewhere else on coda lab I think
actually the formatting and the data
types that's something that the
documentation kind of sorts out so it's
there's a minimal clean up so that you
you do get something that like you see I
data set or something that the similar
set up so i don't have to do really
nasty cleaning yourself so you have
contiguous normal data types they're not
conflicting it's a nice data model so
it's cleaned up yes
it's that's true and that's actually
something that what your one that's one
thing that the auto like most good
submissions that kind of score highly do
something like that implicitly so its
exploration by like automation so you
basically you can make hypothesis okay
this data is not linearly separable
let's dump a kernel across it and see if
it we can make a better predictor so
it's not very something that you can
interpret but it's if your goal is just
to have a good model and that predicts
well this is works pretty nice so I
actually did some submission I it's
actually open source I'll share the link
later and Twitter probably based on the
awesome hyper opt scikit-learn library
but there are some significant
extensions around how I'm defining
different problem spaces in parameter
spaces and this got me like third place
on the new data released so this was
like totally blind test I didn't know
what was the actual outcome and these
are like 30 40 competitors here so it's
pretty good for like two days of work or
something and like just to conclude and
not to brag too much so my point is that
I believe that we shouldn't think in
terms of how many hours we spend but how
many CPU hours we spent for finding a
nice model and we won't automate
everything so yes you still get to keep
your jobs because there's a big part of
the effort that's actually in designing
the initial problem space and there's
that's actually the part where in your
intuition like counts a lot so that's it
thanks
Thank You ty yet today any more
questions we have questions yeah why
don't you take the microphone is better
so there are a lot of different methods
to to check that your model that you
find in the end is okay and works not
only on a training set on but on a more
complete set but given the massive
amount of testing you do at some point
you will run out of possible things you
can test on this data set and if you
will find some model that is best for
the data you have available how can you
make sure without get gathering a load
of petabytes of extra data that your
model is actually good and generalizes
so yeah this is like obvious the
confirmation bias thing that so if you
generate 50,000 different models and one
actually fits by accident it's not
usually the good solution so typically
what what I was doing was we had a
training set like any test set and then
there's a separate validation set so
basically you need to separate these
three times and when you tune the
parameter models you just test on the
first test set and only when you're like
reach an optimum there you test on the
like final test set so that's like that
that's what actually prevents you from
overfitting that badly there's always
the there is some risk that the data
there will be a further data set that
would be like unseen and you might not
fit there but if you got two stages
right it usually means that you're
pretty general but the trick is that you
treat this parameter optimization is
just one like it's kind of like
randomized learning so you're actually
learning new model parameters but you
call them hyper parameters so in essence
you have to test with something that's
like out of that space usually that was
solves the problem and of course yes
do you also build ensembles or single
models so in my particular code I think
I was there's like a different ways to
design to make define design spaces so i
think i was using the in samples just
because there's a psychic learn has
built in ensembles for like decision
trees but the core of my model was
basically to search through the space of
possible pre-processing approaches so
let's say not just feed the actual data
in but do like a kernel approximation do
a random tree embedding to a pc aica and
then fit a model on top of that so there
is a that was like my search space and
it kind of turned out that's pretty good
and in some of this is just like one
particular avenue of search so there is
like a whole like there's an infinity
amount of things that you can try and
and sams are pretty obvious usually on
so thanks by the way if someone's doing
computer vision I would be happy to talk
to them thanks thank you so here comes
the last talk mic or is mike is that
your name ok welcome Mike and good luck
that's good ok and hello everybody up
the slides on German please excuse I
didn't have time to translate them but I
will speak in English but the topic is
has something to do with a location we
are in Germany I would like to talk
about the Germans of foundation or
tysons of their for bunt the subtitle
says we are serving the German pison
community and just wanted let's say a
few words about this organization you
will see the logo they are so viel also
sponsor of this conference here and
there are a foundation the German
foundations that we need some
have a lead structure here because we
needed in Germany to do certain things
and actually all three board members you
are listed here are here at the
conference so if you want to talk to us
we are here we have the boost there and
then at the table so you can talk to us
if you like to mmm what do we do so
these supports the german-speaking pison
community so even though they are a
German organization we try to represent
also the german-speaking pison community
in Australian Switzerland a number of
countries that speak German so a few
things we have our have a website which
tries to be a kind of a hub for this
kind of organization you support user
groups so if your user group in Germany
you can get listed on our website of
people can find you lots of these
support you if you want to set up
something how did the word and some
logistics and stuff like this the also
support events so we have been
organizing 3 pi Conde conferences and
actually been the local organizer for
the European last year here in Berlin
you might PI data was included or was it
and close to this conference and and
then they've been organized this big
european conference i've also organized
other events like the pines in camp
which is a unconference kind of thing
and the pie yum also called organizer
for python conference in hamburg which
is the beginning of September I have
some stickers so you've ever come to
come come there the organized sprints so
these supports with support Springs with
sprint scholarships Travis for bro
scripts that people have to travel
things like this be able to put the ball
prone day and a few other things if you
also do public relationship things we
talked you go to conferences we go to
exhibitions linux fest stuff like this
you write press releases and you try to
get the spread the word about python
then that other organizations companies
in or governmental and nonprofit
organizations get to know about python
we try to block the gutter them and what
we do also be the supportive community
dub it gives organization support if you
need some organization support we have
some financial needs and it's not
unlimited but we have some means to do
it and also they have technical support
that if you need some too
I have a jar of the community charter
set up we have email lists running its
and other things at the runs and virtual
machines for some community projects and
the organizing groups the different
groups that do a different work
organizing the conference like a pie
cody conference public relationships
networking outside working with the
community setting the website they have
a very interesting pineville 3d
programming competition for teenagers
with it programs ready those kind of
things so there's our activities and the
we meet openly once a month ago this is
meeting in IRC is open fiber body and we
also encourage people that not none even
members of the foundation to get into it
and give their opinion and that's that's
how it works and actually if you're
interested you might consider becoming a
member so there are different membership
things you can be options so you can
just a personal member or freelancers or
a company or the other become companies
so if you want to get involved in the
Pisan community and want to do something
becoming a member would be one option
because you could support the Pisan
community there are cleaning directly is
being a member also we want active
members so if you want to get involved
you become the active member so you can
get account that other website and two
things contribute content and do things
so I've already encourage you if you
like to become a member talk to us what
it means and if you have want to have
new information this would be our URL
PHP dot orc you get there and also the
our Twitter so please come talk to us
thank you very much thank you
we have a question yes I have a question
could you briefly explain for somebody
who is not in that Python world what's
the difference between this Python
software for bond and then also PI data
which also seems to be a community both
of you claim to be communities what's
the difference and we're weird linked
together the second question would be
what I do miss at least in Germany is
that there is any activity for young
people my son by chance is 14 by chance
see it is taking a python class but it's
you know it's once a week and they don't
really do it seriously and what I would
love to see is a Python camp or
something you know for a young people
let's say 12 to 18 as you see them in
the US a lot and so that may be a
question even for the community here and
why does that not exist and how could we
establish that thanks for the questions
the first question about paid PI data
and license of el paso a verb and so the
PI data is a data community that's a
kind of a special community inside the
Pisan community and we are a national
way of their forces for the
german-speaking community that we exist
for several years and they try to
represent this this kind of regional
local national expect the
german-speaking that the PI data is kind
of worldwide as the original scale is
different and also with the focus PI
data a specialized on scientists and
scientific data use and be a very wide
focus web development business
development all those kind business
automation deploy them and all those
kind of things it's part of the Python
so that's much wider and we're not only
doing technical things who also have all
this community user groups we support
those local user groups that have
nothing to do this pi data per se but
this Python would it may be open answer
the question and of course the second
point is also very important so if you
have an idea and you want to do
something the about can make to help
unit with us so if you have to have an
ID on even i know i would like to do
Project X velocity I want to do this
then we can help you at all p can even
support you financially if it needs
money you'll need a room on you need
organization you need some legal entity
that's signing a contract just kind of
things we can do and also we know other
people that might be interested we can
make connections there was a person here
in person there they could do it they
cannot do it by themselves but together
this is support of the foundation that's
and if you have idea just you'll have to
talk to you about this and you say this
is good and this works and this guy buys
on this guy working together with us
because we never talk to him because we
don't know it was something like this
maybe I can add some comments to you we
are legally association as you know in
Germany I'm you're talking for so we can
speak with other associations and you
mentioned the kids we are trying to get
this interlude schools made it may be in
kindergarten we had indeed a Titan camp
pi camp in Cologne this was starting 12
13 years old we have a pie move 3d this
is a award should have a live app you
can program from 1390 up to 17 and one
thing is we address other associations
like fo de or the e hoc ass so the
chambers so we're something like a
association they want to speak with this
so we represent them and you can reach
them directly through us and these are
the things like told you and we are of
course dependent on the work we are
doing and you are contributing awesome
thanks or imma maybe he is the founder
of the pie move 3d okay we had already
two competitions and presentations of
the schoolers there were very famous oil
ready all on pie video can watch them
sell just search for pie move CD and
there was a school which of 13 years we
poke and a game Scott in drum in 3d in
blender and made a presentation about
this and a year later he won the keavy
contents the International Kiwi condors
so this means at the moment you can
activate child's and they find something
interesting so I have lots of time and
do very interesting stuff work and they
maybe have a new job a very good job in
the future so there are some on the
foxconn to get this more in the near
future in August there is always a camp
for schoolers so they can have a weekend
there and have a lot of poor coming
stuff so it's not only related to pizen
but maybe it's a good start 24 for your
child gets in the next month and there's
this contest we will open it again
there's not clear at the moment when the
end will be in the past we made it also
that there are sponsors of us so German
give you it's a company which makes
trainings in Cologne so I gave us wombs
and we did a lot of trainings with
schoolers oh yeah and although a lot of
young students joined in and this this
idea is based on learning learning
object oriented programming by using
blender blender is open source and it
has peasantry implemented and every
click you can do you can do in tyson and
project it serves it self describes
takes the first one please the first way
please i know it's always a price for ah
sorry okay yeah that's an idea of course
material and we also like more of this
this is some stuff examples which you
can just use
for showing so for example you can do
show some molecules or some make some
movies some Glenda has a very great
community you can make figures and
that's just some code also sometimes
there are movies which introduce some
difficult window management for example
in blenheim it has a nice qui but
sometimes it's perhaps different than
you maybe I don't know how much people
are knowing blender here Oh some that's
good maybe I should make next year
tutorial about it ok so that's ideal and
there's material and it's all online and
you can try out learn a lot about Tyson
and how to make movies
you